Writing to a file by a client is fairly
straightforward. What the client is doing is actually aggregating
all the writes that is going on into this
Log Segment Data Structure, which is in its memory.
And at some point, it decides that it wants
to flush this Log Segment. And put it on
the disk. And when it decides to do that,
it knows the Stripe Group, this particular Log Segment
it belongs to, and so it is going to take this Log Segment and stripe it on the
Storage Servers that are part of the Stripe
Group. So once it does this write to its
Stripe Group. The client will notify the manager
on the lock segments that are being flushed to
the disc so that the manager has up-to-date information
about the status of the files it manages. So
XFS is a research prototype of a Distributed
File System. There have been other instances of
Distributed File Systems such as. The Android File
System and the Coder File System that were
built at CMU and in fact the Android File System served a community of Users in
the CMU campus in a little lesson we
will return to discussing Distributed File Systems again.
Specifically we'll look at Andrew File System and
discuss the issue of security and privacy for
User Files in a Distributed System. But I
want to leave you with some closing thoughts on the
Exophus File System. First of all, Log based
striping, and particularly sub-setting the Storage Servers over
which you'll stripe the Log. That's a Technical
Innovation. The second Technical Innovation is combining Cooperative Caching
with Dynamic Management of Data and Metadata.
And the last technical nugget is the distributive
Log cleaning, making sure that the responsibility
for cleaning up the Logs on the Disk
is not. Left to one Node, but
it is actually distributed and especially taking advantage
of the fact that the clients, who are
the mutators for the file system, meaning they
are the guys that are writing to the file system, they can keep a count of the
changes that they are making. To the Log Segments
and use that information in the Log Cleaning effectively.